Wonder Woman is one of the most
successful movies and now franchises
that DC has had in a very long time
Wonder Woman was received very well by
the fans and ever since then fans have
been waiting for a sequel
Wonder Woman 1984 and now we have a
release date we have leaked videos
leaked photos an official poster but we
do not have an official trailer yet
however we have learned when we can
expect to see the first teaser trailer
for Wonder Woman 1984 how's it going
everybody it's Warren and if you were
worried that you would have to wait a
lot longer to see the teaser trailer for
Wonder Woman 1984 worry no more patty
Jenkins herself the director of the
first Wonder Woman film and Wonder Woman
1984 of course has confirmed when we are
going to get the first teaser trailer
quick reminder I'm still given away an
Xbox one or ps4 all you have to do to
enter the giveaway is be subscribed to
my channel like the video and leave a
comment down below so a week ago from
today which was Wonder Woman Day patty
Jenkins the director of the film posted
to Twitter the premiere date for the
teaser trailer patty Jenkins posted to
Twitter so excited to bring Wonder Woman
1984 to the fans in Brazil and the world
tune in and see you soon
hashtag CC XP hashtag days of wonder
hashtag finally finally is for sure
because we have waited a very long time
so patty Jenkins has confirmed that she
is going to be releasing the trailer at
CC XP in Brazil which is the Comic Con
experience and thanks to the Business
Wire we know that the date of CC XP this
year is going to be December 8 2019 so
December 8th which is almost just a
month away is when you can expect to see
the first teaser trailer for Wonder
Woman 1984 but if you're worried that
it's just going to be shown at CC XP in
Brazil and nobody else will see it don't
worry because patty Jenkins has implied
that it's going to be released worldwide
on the same day which means it should be
released directly on YouTube and of
course I'll do a reaction on the trailer
the same day Wonder Woman 1984 is
possibly one of the most anticipated
movies for DC coming up DC has done a
very good job recently of hyping up
their new movies coming out but I do
think that I'm most excited to see
Wonder Woman 1984 but let me know what
you think how excited are you to finally
get a trailer for the Wonder Woman
sequel and let me know how excited you
are to see Wonder Woman 1984 when it
comes out next year on June 5th of 2020
be sure to leave a comment hit that like
button and be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Wonder Woman 1984 as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof